on the 40th anniversary of the Beirut
Barracks bombings President Biden had to
cut a press conference short because
jihadis attacked a US military base in
Syria I apologize I have to go to the
situation with another issue that I have
to deal with but thank you thank you
thank you us currently has about 900
troops in Syria and almost three times
that number in Iraq where Islamic
militants have also targeted American
troops since the war in the Holy Land
broke out a couple weeks ago fortunately
the Americans have thus far made it out
relatively unscathed but the war is
clearly expanding and threatening to
pull the US once again into allout war
in the Middle East with the geop and
disarray many republican leaders have
made a habit of asking in terms of
Crisis what President Reagan might do
usually the question defies easy answer
because Reagan's been dead for almost 20
years years and he hasn't been in office
in 34 years and political circumstances
change over time but in this case we
actually do have an answer because
Ronald Reagan dealt with a far more
devastating version of this exact
problem almost at the exact same spot 40
years ago 40 years and one day ago two
trucks hit a building housing American
troops in Lebanon and those trucks were
rigged with bombs and they blew up the
attack killed 241 American servicemen
along with 58 French military personnel
and six
civilians and what did President Reagan
do that old cowboy invoked by so many
reflexive warhawks Ronald
Reagan declined to retaliate in any
serious way and then he quickly withdrew
American forces from the
country this is not the answer that the
Gipper most Idol idolatrous and
belligerent invokers might expect or
desire but that's what really happened
because Ronald Reagan one of the best
foreign policy presidents we've ever had
consistently sought to avoid direct
overt military
confrontation despite his bellicose
reputation Reagan was reticent to get
the United States bogged down in Foreign
Wars with ambiguous strategic objectives
as The Usual Suspects beat the war drums
louder and Lou over the coming weeks
remember that the president whose motto
was peace through strength in almost
identical circumstances famously and
wisely said no I'm Michael NES this the
Michael nlls
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the show guess what I
had for dinner last night I'll give you
one guess you guessed at good ranchers I
had delicious usually I do the beef and
the steak and the ground beef and all
that the chicken and nice chicken
cutlets that were the most magnificent
chicken cutlets I've had in a long time
this episode of course brought to you by
good ranchers get great me at a secure
price and 30 bucks off your order with
code nolles kwes go to goodranchers.com
use code nolles kwes today gret a
thunberg is striking in solidarity with
the
Palestinians which is strange because I
thought in order to go on strike you had
to have a job but she skipped the that
step she's now just she's on strike not
for the sun monster right now it is for
Hamas we will get to that in just a
moment first though the war is only
getting worse you might
recall I guess a week and a half or so
ago there was a news report that came
out that the Israelis had bombed a
church a very old church in Gaza perhaps
one of the oldest churches in the world
with roots all the way back in Antiquity
and which was expanded by Crusaders in
the 12th
century uh that turned out to be fake
news the church had not been bombed
which is good because you think why
would the Israelis bomb a church Hamas
isn't storing weapons in a church Hamas
doesn't have a Command Center in a
church why would they do it so luckily
that was fake News until yesterday now
then now the church has been bombed this
is a Greek Orthodox Church in Gaza it is
the Church of St
poros and uh people were
killed according to Palestine Health
officials they say 16 people were killed
we don't know it's the fog of War we do
know however that some people were
killed because relatives of former
Republican Congressman Justin Amash were
Sheltering in the church and were
killed Palestinian officials had said at
least 500 Muslims and Christians had
taken shelter in St perious Church uh we
we don't know those real numbers
but Israel needs to answer for this okay
I am as big a defender of the state of
Israel's right to defend itself as there
is
obviously the Israeli government has a
right to protect itself after Hamas
militants Slaughter hund over a thousand
people and rape and pillage and burn and
do all sorts of terrible things and take
hostages
but the Israelis have to answer for why
they hit this church and in fact they
have Charlie Kirk raised this point
yesterday and uh an Israeli spokesperson
for the IDF said I understand your
feelings and respect them we did not
Target that or any church we struck a
Hamas military operative who coordinated
rocket fire toward Israel from that
vicinity he was a legitimate Target we
will continue to be careful of any
sensitive facility will you I don't know
I mean that I appreciate the answer I'm
glad the IDF is answering for it but
clearly they weren't all that careful
because they blew up an old church a
really old church and my reaction to
this even is giving me pause
because every single innocent person who
is killed is worth any number of old
churches human beings are worth much
more than beautiful old
stuff and yet because we we've become so
callous to the death of
Innocence it's when the really old stuff
when the art when the buildings when the
culture get destroyed that that
sometimes pulls on our heartstrings even
more we feel this is such a loss it can
never be replicated fortunately I don't
think the church was totally destroyed
but it appears to have been severely
damaged and and that feeling of loss for
our culture that feeling of loss for
beautiful art and in this case something
deeper than art you're talking about a
house of God oriented toward the worship
of God points us and reminds us of of
the the most significant loss in this
war or any War which is the loss of life
for innocent civilians which we right
off and we we we use euphemisms and we
say it's collateral damage collateral
damage means the death of innocent
people not just going on in the Middle
East and the Ukraine war the fact that
Joe Biden has no interest in wiing
winding down the Ukraine war the fact
that there have been multiple
opportunities for peace and Joe Biden
has said no thank you why because the
the warhawks in Washington say that the
war in Ukraine is great for us because
we get to deplete the Russian military
that's another euphemism and we get to
we we get to advance our strategic
objectives whatever those may be and we
don't even have to sacrifice American
troops we can just spend some money but
while we're depleting the Russian
military innocent people are being
killed and while this war drags on
innocent people are being killed while
this war in in the Holy Land drags on
innocent people are being killed and
irreplaceable art and artifacts of our
culture are being destroyed as well so
the question is even even if this is a
legit answer from the
IDF the question then has to be what is
the objective here is the objective the
total Destruction of Hamas it's a good
objective I'm all for it is the
objective the total Destruction of Gaza
uh that's a little more
dubious Israel does a generally a very
good job of protecting civilians
compared to other people certainly
compared to
Hamas but do we want to see the Gaza
stripto destroyed is the objective here
regime change in
Iran is that in the interests of the
United States is that in the interest of
global stability what's the objective
here it's not just a question that the
IDF has to answer it's a question
especially that the United States has to
answer because the United States keeps
getting bogged down in these wars now
for decades that don't seem to have a
clear point to
them and in the
meantime the destruction only
expands
against things that are irreplaceable
not just buildings not just art but
people too question is how does this end
speaking of terrorism Yours
Truly has been accused of terrorism by a
professor at Harvard this professor at
Harvard uh came to my attention because
I got a Google alert about some gay news
Outlet it's called The Advocate and uh
the the Gayo titled this this article
quote stochastic terrorism links between
the GOP right-wing influencers and
Neo-Nazi violence and then you see there
on the cover it's some
neo-nazis and then a picture of Libs of
Tik Tok and then me that and somehow
somehow if you connect the dots we're
lives of Tik Tok an Orthodox Jewish
woman and I a man who got in trouble
with this gay outlet for
[Music]
saying
I'm they're going to come after you you
don't need to have an AK-47 you don't
need to set off a bomb you just need to
use words that they don't like and
they're going to use their positions of
influence at the arguably most
prestigious School in the country and in
the federal government to stop you
that's not good now we got to prepare
ourselves for a political battle here
and when you want to prepare your body
and feel really good and have a great
dinner you've got to check out good
ranchers right now go to good Ranch
.com/srobiyt
chicken cutlets from good ranchers I
usually just focus on the beef cuz you
know I only eat good ranchers what three
times a week four times a week if I'm
lucky and so I want to I want to focus
it on the beef and the steak and the
burgers best burger you ever had but so
I go for the chicken magnificent best
chicken cutlets I've had in a very very
long time right now good ranchers is
throwing in a treat for our listeners 30
bucks off your order with code nolles
head on over right now to
goodranchers.com use code nolles get 30
bucks off with free express shipping
code NES KW for 30 bucks off your box at
goodranchers.com goodranchers American
Meat delivered speaking of terrorism
Karen
jeanpierre was just asked about the
surge in anti-semitic attacks since this
war broke out there have been a lot of
of new attacks on Jews in the United
States what does kjp have to say about
it this level of concern right now about
the potential rise of anti-Semitism in
light of everything that going on in
Israel so a couple of things um look um
uh we have not seen uh any credible uh
threats I know there's been always
questions about uh credible threats uh
and so uh just want to make sure that
that's out there but look uh Muslim and
those perceived uh to be Muslim have
endured a disproportionate uh number of
hate fueled attacks and certainly
President Biden understands that many of
our Muslim Arab AR Arab Americans and
palestini American loved ones and
neighbors are worried about the hate
being directed at their communities well
hold on hold on I the question was what
do you think about all the attacks on
Jews and then Karen jair's answer is yes
islamophobia is a really big problem no
no no hold on we can we can talk about
islamophobia in a second but I'm I'm
asking about the attacks on Jews yes yes
the the Palestine supporters have
suffered greatly
no
we're but Karine jeampier can't answer
this the White House can't answer this
the Democrats broadly can't answer this
this is a wedge issue in the Democratic
party the Democrat Party previously had
been a big supporter of Israel both
parties in the United States were big
supporters of
Israel the question of Israel became
more of a partisan issue during the
Obama administration because Barack
Obama hated BB Netanyahu and BB
Netanyahu leader of Israel responded a
little bit in kind and cozied up to
Donald Trump and doesn't have a great
relationship with Joe Biden so Israel
support all of a sudden becomes more of
a republican thing and because
especially American evangelicals are so
uh vocally supportive of Israel even in
the popular culture support for Israel
has has become coded as more of a
right-wing thing than a leftwing thing
and also
because Israel is a symbol of
colonialism much as uh European States
in Africa have been symbols of
colonialism much as the United States of
America has been a symbol of colonialism
the uh intersectional left has taken up
the cause of the stateless Palestinians
against the nation state of
Israel the the oppression narrative is
on the side of the Palestinians now not
on the side of Jews even though the
state of Israel was established for the
Jews in large part because of the uh
historical victimhood of the Jewish
people that doesn't matter what have you
done for me lately now that ideology is
backing the Palestinians still there are
a lot of Israel supporters in the
Democrat Party so they can't get a clean
win either way but if Joe Biden's got to
pick a
side they are going to side at least a
little bit with the Palestinians against
the Israelis that's where the Democrat
base is today and Joe Biden has never
been a conviction politician he doesn't
have any actual beliefs he wakes up in
the morning he licks his finger he
figures out which way the wind is
blowing and certainly among Democrats
the wind is blowing against the state of
Israel for Palestine so what do you say
about anti-Semitism Joe I say
islamophobia is a big big problem now
speaking of the future and the youths
you've been asking us for an alternative
in kids media it is finally here the
daily wire just launched bent key our
brand new kids entertainment platform we
are all sick of Hollywood pushing
leftist propaganda on our kids now there
is finally an answer for those of us
looking for Children's shows that we can
trust bent key is brand new it's
available to download right now it's an
entirely new company from the daily wire
dedicated to creating the next
generation of Timeless stories that
transport kids into a world of Adventure
imagination and joy this is exactly what
parents have been waiting for I don't
just say that as someone who works for
the daily wire I say that because I am
one of those parents I do not want my
kids to see all this insane leftist
propaganda I have been as gung-ho as
anybody in this building for the kids
entertainment since it was announced
something like 18 months ago takes a lot
of time takes a lot of money to create
this content and the content is
absolutely fabulous we have tested it on
my children no children were harmed in
the testing of this content in fact my
two and a half-year-old absolutely loves
it uh it I had high expectations for it
already because I know there are a lot
of talented people in this building it
exceeded my expectations I could not
have imagined that DW was going to
provide all of this for its members and
they're not increasing the price of an
annual membership which to me is insane
but they don't want to do it so it's the
greatest value ad that we've ever given
it's a $99 value that you get completely
free goes to show you that we don't just
talk about changing culture we put it
into action we really believe in what
we're doing and as I said if you're
already a dw+ member you already have b
key just download the app to start
streaming now if you're not a member
there has never been a better time to
join you get all of the dailywire plus
cont content that you know and love plus
bent key at no additional cost go to
daily.com subscribe right now to start
streaming the next generation of kids
entertainment speaking of the
kids and
Palestine Greta
thunberg is she's taking a break from
protesting in favor of Gaia and the sun
gods and all the rest of the weather
religion and she is standing with Gaza
and Palestine uh Greta thunberg just
posted a tweet says week 270 today we
strike in solidarity with Palestine and
Gaza 270
weeks at that point I think you just
lose your job but she never had a job so
she's just striking striking is her job
and usually she strikes for the benefit
of the environmental left which uh
profits and grows in power by uh
consolidating the socially and
politically accept cable energy use but
today she's decided she's going to
strike for Gaza this is true of the
broader left it's not just the White
House it's not just the professional
activist the sort of maranet of the
liberal regime Greta thunberg it is also
uh Justin Trudeau the leader of
America's evil Top Hat Canada who just
tweets out quote as members of the
Palestinian Arab and black Muslim
communities gathered for prayer
yesterday I wanted them to know this we
know you're worried and hurting we are
here for you we will not stop advocating
for civilians to be protected and for
international law to be upheld I know a
lot of people are confused about which
side to be on here because a lot of
people say we don't really have a dog in
this fight the holy land is very far
away this is a conflict that's gone on
in its present form for well over 100
years and it's a conflict that has gone
on broadly for uh millennia and so we
we don't really pick a side here uh but
this the side is going to pick you I
guess is how I would say it if you look
around and look at the people who were
supporting Palestine Hamas versus the
people who are supporting the state of
Israel broadly speaking you are going to
see the most prominent leftists who are
wrong about the most things in the most
egregious ways they are generally going
to be on the side of Palestine
and the people with whom you generally
tend to agree are who who are right
about generally the right number of
things they are broadly going to be
supportive of the Israeli government
it's just the I'm not saying that it's a
perfect one toone I'm not saying that
all the interests are totally aligned
but that's what happens Rashida Talib
AOC Ilan
Omar Justin Trudeau Justin Castro Greta
thunberg Joe B all the rest of them they
are pretty vocally on the side of the
Palestinians and if the libs if the
people who are most WR about everything
are uniformly on the pal on the side of
the Palestinians then probably that's
not the right side to totally be on
right politics is a team sport and I
know people don't like that and it makes
people uncomfortable and we all bemoan
tribalism that's another one of these
words that cropped up in the last six
seven years that is largely meaningless
but it's it's just a word that's going
around like a meme but politics is Tri
and here we're talking about one of the
most ancient tribes in the world and a
multiple ancient tribes actually uh
fighting over this and
so it seems ill advised to put yourself
on the side of of uh Greta thunberg and
Justin Trudeau and the the squad in
favor of Palestine Liberation because
the argument for Palestine Liberation is
the anti-colonial argument which is
ultimately just an anti-european anti-
dirty rotten white man argument uh to to
destroy uh anything resembling Western
Civilization that's that's what it's
about someone put it in a pithy way
which was uh a lot of the left doesn't
hate Israel because they're Jews they
hate Israel because they're white and
because uh the state of Israel uh
appears to have a lot of resemblances to
any other British colonial project much
like the United States and the arguments
that are being wielded right now against
the state of Israel will and in fact are
currently being wielded against the us
as well that's not a it's not a perfect
overlap of Interest though which is why
I say the US interest in this war
remains it has always been and it
remains to contain the war and speaking
of picking sides John Stewart was just
asked from
Apple and and he had this new show it's
called the problem with John Stewart his
first big show since he left the daily
show and the show gets canceled pretty
early why did Apple TV cancel John
Stewart there are two competing
narratives one says they canceled him
because he had low ratings the other
narrative clearly being leaked by his
team is that they canceled him because
he wanted to criticize China and he
wanted to criticize artificial
intelligence and Apple is very warm with
China and with artificial intelligence
so they had an ideological disagreement
they shut him up which is it well we got
the numbers some estimates put JN
Stewart's viewership on this Apple TV
show as low as 40,000 us
homes that is
nothing that that is barely a blip
forget about compared to a network TV
audience or even a cable TV audience
compared to a small podcast those are
bad
numbers so okay he had the low ratings
but then the reports say that he was
planning shows on China on Israel
actually too and on AI and apple because
it does a lot of business with China
Apple which would collapse if we if we
decoupled with China and uh artificial
intelligence obviously is important to
Apple uh they don't like those topics so
they kill it which is it which destroyed
JN Stewart's
show the answer is both it's obviously
both John Stewart has always had low
ratings he was a cultural phenomenon
when he had the Daily Show on Comedy
Central that show didn't get a lot of
viewers it was relatively low rated but
the people who watched it tended to be
journalists and the chattering political
class concentrated in the coast it's
very liberal who had an outsized
microphone so they made a big deal out
of his show Even though relatively few
people watched it in the
country the low ratings can be
forgiven as long as you are dancing to
the tune that the liberal Elite are
playing that's the issue when when John
Stewart was dancing as the court gesture
of the liberal regime which is what his
job was at The Daily Show they loved him
and they made a big deal out of him and
they made him famous and they made him
wealthy even though not a lot of people
watched his show but now that he's maybe
turning against some of what the the
ruling class want especially in China
and AI well now those low ratings are
not going to be forgiven and they're
going to take away his Fame and they're
going to take away his money and he's
going to see how illusory all of those
things actually were and he's going to
learn lesson that a lot of us have
forgotten which is true in politics and
it's true in business and it's true in
all of public life he who pays the piper
calls the
tune now speaking of dancing to other
people's tune I've got a very disturbing
story that just came out and it's
disturbing in that it's super creepy and
spooky and kind of zombie like and it's
just in time for Halloween but it's it's
actually a satisfying story because it
vindicates a lot of old wisdom and the
story is
this blood transfusions might change
your
personality if you get a lot of people
get blood
transfusions there is scientific
evidence that you don't just get blood
and you don't just get platelets you get
an increased risk of
certain diseases okay maybe you could
say well it's just a protein or
something was going along with the blood
and you get
potentially changes in your personality
and your mood and your tastes and it's
really really weird researchers at the
Kolinski Institute in Sweden published a
major study that showed that a cause of
spontaneous brain hemorrhage could be
transmitted via blood transfusion as I
said that could just be some protein or
something like
that but it might go deeper than that
and there's a lot of evidence that it
does go deeper five years ago a study by
Geneva University reported that nearly
half of patients reported changes in
their behavior and values after
receiving blood transfusions there have
also been well popular well publicized
stories rather of people who had organ
transplants and then their tastes
changed in the US there was a
47-year-old woman who had a lung
transplant from an 18-year-old and then
immediately had a craving for beer and
fried chicken which were things that
this woman had not previously craved but
that every 18-year-old in the country
does crave the researchers interviewed
seven people who received blood
transfusions uh for things like hip
replacements and other surgeries they
found out three of the seven believed
that their personalities had changed one
said he slept and dreamt a lot more than
before another said his sense of taste
had changed and he found this worrying
he said I hope that the donor's blood
cannot take
over this is really great news even
though it's spooky and creepy because
this is a Vindication of classical
anthropology this is a vindication
of the old way of of viewing human
nature not the new way of viewing human
the new way of viewing human nature is
that we're all just Machines man we're
like computers Plug and Play you know
and we're just we're we're like a hard
drive and and different like just like
in different parts of a machine you can
just pull out our parts and they're
interchangeable and you can plug them
into new people it's no big deal the
classical understanding of human nature
is is not that the classical
understanding of human nature is we are
an integrated hole that we are a primary
substance that you can't just plug and
play our different parts like on a car
you know on a car you can go in you take
out a catalytic converter from one car
you can put it into another car and it's
going to work just fine you can pull out
the transmission here you can plug it in
because to use the old terminology a car
and all these other created things
they're just artifacts we make them so
they're not they're not totally
integrated in the way that a human being
is a human being being primary substance
made by
God one problem for this old view of
human nature in recent years has been
that it seems like with organ
transplants we actually are kind of like
the catalytic inverter we actually are
like a car or like any other artifact
you just plug us and play us and there's
so many people especially prominent
voices in the academy and in the
government and in the cultural Elite who
say yeah we're just machines we think we
have free will we think we have souls we
think we have desires and longings and
meaning but it's all just fake it's an
illusion made by firing pistons in our
brain even the term Pistons you know to
compare it to a car and uh so you're
just deluding yourself you're just
but maybe not maybe our our organs don't
just plug and play like that maybe
actually it's all part of that one
person and you could get a blood
transfusion and things start to go a
little haywire and you start you start
craving chicken and beer and you start
maybe they're they're really for us and
we are one thing that is integrated not
just in our body but take it it one step
further maybe we're integrated Body and
Soul maybe maybe we're actually not
machines but human beings who
knew every wise person for all of
history is the answer until very
recently and then we said those guys are
dumb idiots and we're modern and we have
cell phones so we know that that they're
all wrong and we're right about
everything well maybe not maybe we
actually are human
beings speaking of the Vindication of
traditional wisdom this is going to this
is a shocking headline if you're driving
you got to pull over if you're standing
up please sit down if you take a deep
breath turns out that when the uh
Kentucky Democrat Governor
Basher uh during the coid lockdowns
decided to let a bunch of criminals out
of prison turns out that those criminals
that he let out of prison they they went
on and committed more Crim
crimes this I mean how could you can't
blame Andy Basher here right how could
he have possibly seen it coming that
people who are known for committing a
lot of
crimes if you let them out of their
punishment and you just set them free in
society they're going to commit more
crimes how could any modern liberal who
recognizes that no one is personally
responsible for their crimes and
actually it's society's fault and we
need with the the prison industrial
complex is a terrible form of Oppression
and slavery and actually we just need to
give people hugs and let them free and
let them be there they don't even have
free will we can't
anyway who could have
guessed normal people is who could have
guessed ordinary normal people who have
the wisdom of the ages and even a modum
of Common Sense Once Again Vindicated
over the liberal
Elite we're looking pretty good aren't
we when you want to look really really
good you got to check out jenus cell
right now go to genucell.com our friends
over at genell have launched a new
product called genell 3 which works fast
on your under eye bags and puffiness
genu cell 3 is smooth and luxurious and
it uses advanced technology to deliver
complex vitamins and minerals directly
to your face for instant hydration it's
like Gatorade for your skin this new
genus cell technology keeps your skin
looking young and healthy for years to
come the genus cell fall Classics
package also includes a jawline
treatment for a more firm neck and
jawline as well as genell's anti-
wrinkle moisturizer and deep Firming
Serum right now go to genucell.com
wle for extra discounts on this amazing
fall package get your skin ready for the
cold and dry weather if you don't look
and feel your absolute best you will get
your money back no questions guaranteed
that is genucell.com you know I love
this company I love the founders Copic
Christian from Egypt who fled over here
for the American dream go to
genucell.com
SLK
Wes my favorite comment yesterday is
from Broden MacArthur 3955 who says I
like to listen to Michael because he
remains calm and collected during such
crazy times I tend to get frustrated and
he is my
Xanax I I think that's a compliment
Michael nolles the human Xanax I don't
is
that I'll I will choose to take that as
a compliment thank you very
much nearly 70% of inmates released by
Basher through commutations during Co
went on to reoffend with some committing
violent felonies like assault and
homicide 172 individuals whose sentences
were commuted by Bashir in 2020 the
majority of them 882 went on to commit
felonies then an additional 252
committed misdemeanors leaving just over
500 who have not committed any crimes
yet turns out you can't fix problems
just by wishing them away you can't and
it turns out that refusing to punish
criminals is not compassionate it's not
charitable it's not
compassionate toward the the future
victims and the past victims but
especially the future victims of their
crimes had Basher just done his job and
been normal and locked up the
criminals
882 no I'm sorry more than over a
thousand victims would not have been
victimized over thousand people would
not have been victims of crimes some of
which were violent
felonies homicide some of so people are
dead because Andy Basher thought it
would be really compassionate to let
criminals out of prison that's not
compassionate it's not charitable it's
not compassionate or charitable to
toward the criminals
either Plato talks about this in gorgus
all these turns out all these really old
guys they were right about a lot of
things it is an act of love to punish a
criminal because the criminal has
something wrong with him he's kind of
like a disease he's got defects of his
will and his intellect and he does bad
things and when you do bad things that
harms you it harms your
soul it
will uh compromise your potential
Eternal reward I mean ultimately it
could send you to hell but even if you
don't believe in the soul even if you
don't believe in religion or anything
that if free wise person throughout all
of history is believed in even if you
don't believe in that even just from the
perspective of life on Earth if you're a
criminal and you keep murdering people
and doing drugs and getting involved
with the wrong crowd and you're you're
going to harm yourself you're not going
to live a good life you're not going to
be happy you're going to wind up either
dead of an overdose or killed in some
violent crime or you're going to wind up
destroying your body you're going to
you're going to be living a bad life
nobody says you know I love my child and
I really want my child to have a good
life and that's why I'm going to
encourage my child to to get involved in
crime it's not good it's not good for
these people
either it is cruelty to do this it is a
it is the kind of negligence that is so
typical of liberalism on the left and on
the right which says that other people
they're not my problem other people
they're not my business no I'm just
going to do me and you do you and I'm an
island and tire under myself and how
does it affect you look man how does it
affect you if we radically redefine some
social question how does it affect you
if we radically social engineer some
aspect of society oh because I live in
society with other people and it warps
the universe in which I am attempting to
live a good and flourishing life it
affects me because man is a political
animal and social creature
and we're not just islands and atams
floating in outer space how does it
affect me because some stupid criminal
released by Andy Basher could murder me
God forbid that's how it affects
me we got to ditch this crazy
ideological hyper individualism on the
left and on the right it's different on
the left and the right on the right it's
don't take any of my money and on the
left it's don't tell me what weird stuff
I can do in back Alleyways at night but
the the point of it is ultimately the
same it's a denial of society and it
emisat all of us uh speaking of Crime
and Punishment a judge a Democrat judge
in
Colorado has just greenlid a campaign to
keep Trump off the ballot in
Colorado uh this Judge Sarah Wallace was
appointed by the Democrat Governor Jared
paus and uh she has denied a motion by
Trump in the Colorado GOP to throw out a
lawsuit seeking to block Trump from from
appearing on the ballot in Colorado and
why are they going to block Trump from
appearing on the ballot because he's an
evil rapist
insurrectionist Ukraine colluding Russia
colluding mean old orange man who we
really hate and an invisible Inc in the
Constitution it says that mean orange
men can't be on the ballot I think I
think that's pretty much the substance
of the lawsuit and this Colorado judge
says Okay can go
ahead or that's the substance of the
campaign rather and the judge says yeah
the campaign can go ahead sure
okay the last time we had a situation
like this I will remind you was 1860
people sometimes say that in 1860
Abraham Lincoln didn't appear on the
ballot in the southern states which is
not quite true because elections were
conducted differently than they are
today you didn't have a formal ballot on
a computer screen or even just printed
out it was the parties would produce the
ballots and the GOP didn't even invest
in the South because they were never
going to win and GOP was a new party
with not a lot of resources but the
effect of it was basically that Abraham
Lincoln was not a candidate that one
could even really plausibly vote for in
a lot of the
country and then when he got elected
president that was a cause of the Civil
War because half the country felt that
it it didn't have any representation it
didn't really have any say whatsoever
it's this is not an identical situation
but it's pretty close if the Liberals
succeed at kicking Donald Trump off the
ballot in 2024
it's going to tell us two things one
it's going to tell us that Trump is
obviously electable one of the silliest
lines I hear is that Donald Trump can't
win the general election he can't win a
general election which I know is false
because he won at least one general
election he did a lot of people who said
the same thing in 2016 Donald Trump can
never win a general election they were
quite surprised when he won the general
election in 2016 but then they use the
uh dubious election of 2020 to say well
see now he actually he can't win on he
could not saying he will I'm just saying
he could so it's going to it the fact
that the Dems want to keep him off the
ballot shows you they don't think it's
going to be a slam dunk to defeat him at
The Ballot Box even with the vote
harvesting even with the dropboxes even
with all of their nonsense and all of
their shenanigans that open the
elections to fraud they still are not
convinced they can beat them at The
Ballot Box so they want to they want to
prevent voters from even having the
choice at The Ballot Box that's the
first thing it's going to tell you the
second thing it tells you is
we are dangerously close to not
having much of anything in common as a
country we are dangerously close to the
conditions that we were at in 1860 and
I'm not one of these catastrophists who
says that we're always going to be on
the brink of Civil War and we're all
going to I'm certainly not encouraging
Civil War by any means but it could
happen just like people sometimes say do
you think we're living in the end times
my answer is I don't think we are but
someone's going to be living in the end
times I guess we could be that's kind of
how I feel about Civil War I'm not
saying that we're headed for civil war
but we could be civil wars happen and
the Liberals would appear to be
cultivating the conditions to make it
much more likely the rest of the show
continues now you do not want to miss it
become a member and use code nolles canw
a check out for 2 months free on all
annual
[Music]
plans
am